cette image était attendue depuis plus
d'une décennie par les habitants de
maurepas et de la verrière
les élus locaux ont officiellement
inauguré le nouveau pont schuller ce
mardi 5 février
les travaux qui ont duré deux ans a
permis de doubler des voies de
circulation sur un axe emprunté par
vingt mille véhicules chaque jour
aujourd'hui c'est l'aboutissement non
seulement le pont il est efficace
puisqu'il n'y a plus de bouchons
d'entrée d'huile donc c'est un vrai
confort pour l'ensemble des habitants
dont seulement promotionnelles en cours
c'est une facilité d'accès non seulement
à la gare de la verrière en bus mais
aussi pour ceux qui sont en voiture qui
souhaitent rejoindre la nationale 10
pour aller travailler
des voies de circulations douces plus
larges ont également été créés pour
relier maurepas à la verrière bien plus
sécuritaire
quitte avant les piétons
vélo ont leur propre chemin de cette
manière on va favoriser aussi j'espère
un déplacement
sans voiture coût total de l'opération 9
millions d'euros prise en charge à
hauteur de 30% par saint quentin en
yvelines et à 70% par le département
l'état et la région
nous l'avons fait parce que nous
considérons opposé la route transports
en commun c'est une aberration c'est sur
la route qu'on va faire rouler le les
futurs transport en site propre qui
relieront la verrière et rap
et c'est sur ces ponts en imitant les
embouteillages que on arrive à limiter
la pollution et limiter le stress
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
nouveau pont schuller une exposition
retraçant l'histoire du projet a été
mise en place à la sortie de la gare de
la verrière